hey zareen hi Edmond what are we looking
at right here we're looking at two foxes
which are they are phasing in and out of
existence is he's not me chasing one
another around a triangle of some sort
that's right that triangle is actually
the tri which is what this game is named
after try so try which is it all
capitals TR I is a first-person platform
puzzle game in which you an unnamed
mysterious I guess wanderer or Explorer
just I suddenly thrown into this world
and you come across this shifty being
I'm not really sure who or what he is
very spiritual yeah it looks a bit i'm
gonna say Asian influences yeah well I
got that vibe as well I mean this game
definitely has all the Asian influences
and like you can see unless tetex and
the way the way it's designed in like
the myths and stuff it pulls from like
the Foxes being gods and such but some
the main sell this game is try the try
itself so it's this artifact that you
pick up which allows you or gives you
the power to create triangles right so
yeah I just saw you made a platform
there and climbed up that's right so can
you only make a triangle from a certain
point in the level or make one anywhere
you can make one anywhere but if the
triangles too steep you won't be able to
run out of it and the way it conveys
that is if if the trunk was yellow it
means you can run off like it and like
actually get onto a bit the triangle is
red like the ones over here you're
actually unable to uh you know climb up
the morning I saw you you just shattered
them yeah so the try it also gives you
the power to destroy triangles take a
break and destroy triangles well it's
fascinating really and like I guess the
whole overarching goal of each level is
to collect these statues that you have
to make a way to and draw Fox they're
all [ __ ] statues yep so these temples
are all like from the gods which
represented by the foxes that wander
around
and you collect all these statues to
finish it each level so it's kind of
like you know each level has its own
puzzles and the puzzles get gradually
more and more topped it looks like a lot
of um platforming making triangles to
get across gaps and stuff yeah it's very
physics-based thing it's basic as in
like you know you need to physically get
oh my poem is that you mean right yes
gravity to think about well except you
don't take full damage so if you fall
you're fine I've not actually died in
this game yet although like you know
falling is frustrating and you do pick
up like boxes and such which you just
saw there some boxes there um to like
throw aside and things do get more they
gradually add more layers of things to
the talking to mrs. near the big the
beginning of the game yeah so this this
was like the second or third level but
like this is when they start introducing
the ability to destroy triangles and
it's not straightforward as you just
right click on a triangle you need to
you can't destroy a triangle which is
supporting another triangle right okay
um so that you know there's limitations
placed on that and I thought it was cool
actually in this this part where you see
like triangles falling from the sky but
then gradually wow you pick up what's
called the second try which grants you
the ability to walk on the triangles Wow
ok so the Apple mentioned red triangles
are actually not a problem anymore oh
well so yeah it's not I thought it was
it might have been manipulating gravity
at such at first but it looks like
you're just walking up them you just
stick to them yeah that's right so you
can draw triangles to draw like a path
up like I've done here but the first
triangle always needs to be a yellow one
so you can't just draw like a whole like
you know path or triangles any way you
want the first one has to be connecting
right and also be yellow right um so you
know the puzzles do gradually get a bit
more complex a word like bendy more mind
editing yeah yeah I can see that you're
having to pick up a box and woke up a
wall and all that kind of stuff so
what's this circle blue circle thing
around this mike was at the limit to how
big you can make your triangle yes
that's right so you can only draw you
can't draw like massive triangles
everywhere they do have to be
in a certain like area and of course you
know as all puzzle platformer games
usually do nowadays have there's a whole
switches mechanic like pressing buttons
down picking up boxes to be ashore
things you know open up in doorways yeah
remind me very much of portal and like
quantum conundrum in an antechamber or
that size of the games yeah and the
other thing I really liked about this
game was it wasn't just a straight up
like puzzle platformer like there was
foreshadowing in the game um like this
guy he mentions the power of the tri may
like be like evil or something or even
turn you make you crazy so I thought
that was really interesting so the
narrative it plays more of a part in try
yeah and like of course the foxes as
well I think they will eventually maybe
do something yeah it's about lots of
emphasis on the theme I say yeah
definitely the other thing I wanted to
mention was there's different ways to
solve puzzles you don't always have to
take like there's no one definite route
and I thought that was a that was cool
that there's lots of possibilities I
guess when you can make triangles and a
thinner there must be quite a few ways
absolutely so is this out nows rain I
think by the time this video goes off
yes okay cool this will be out on steam
so you can check it out there
you